bonjour et bienvenue 7,8 de l'été je
vais vous emmener en balade autour de
saint quentin en yvelines et pour cela
je me suis épaulé de deux guides sportif
julie et christophe ce sont des ballades
qu'on peut réaliser à la fois en roller
en vtt ou bien entendu à pied on va
commencer d'abord par retrouver christ
alors on va le retrouver du côté d'el en
cours et on va regarder la carte du
parcours ensemble point de départ le
parc des coudrais ensuite il faudra
escalader la sévère difficile colline de
l'emploi un petit passage par le bassin
de la meuse pour finir par un long
moment dans la forêt de maurepas à
l'écrit stop c'est à toi
bonjour je m'appelle christophe
aujourd'hui je vous propose une balade
sorel en cours intitulé entre ville et
bae nature c'est une bague qui peut être
réalisé en une heure trente pour des
sportifs en 45 minutes elle peut être
faite c'est une balade à ces sportives
comme le vous le voyez aujourd'hui là on
se trouve sur le palais des congrès et
je vais vous présenter la base allez
suivez moi
s'il faut savoir si on peut parler des
coûts devrait donc au départ de la
balade c'est le premier parc créé sur
saint quentin en yvelines les actes que
vous voyez ici au pari découdre et font
partie du patrimoine labellisée ville
d'art et d'histoire depuis 2006
parce que c'est la ballade là
l'une des meilleures balades proposées
sur l'ensemble des balles on retrouve un
peu tous les terrains tous les terrains
de la forêt il ya des choses sympas les
bords des étangs des
le gros coup de coeur basset a connu des
records
déjà à gravir et puis une fois qu'on est
là où on voit tout 50 en ligne et quand
c'est bien dégagé on a même eu à voir la
toile elle est vraiment un point saint
palais
plusieurs parcours enfin s'offrent à
vous faut savoir que
en sortant des sentiers on peut trouver
de
très beaux parcours
sportif
j'ai deux coups tient demain donc c'est
l'entrée de la forêt domaniale de
maurepas aucun gros denis une grosse
grosse côte à monter et de belles
descentes derrière
allez on va faire durant leur maintenant
avec julie une façon de découvrir les
sites les plus connus de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines voyez la carpe
et puis s'il fait chaud vous pourrez
allez vous rafraîchira l'apc de huy en
cours ou alors sur les terrasses des
cafés et restaurants du quartier de
villas roi suivez le guide
alors c'est une balade qui fait environ
14 km vous pouvez la faire à la fois en
roller à la fois à pied voire à vélo il
n'y a pas de souci elle est destinée
essentiellement aux familles alors pour
tout ce qui est roller on va partir à
partir de 6 7 ans mais sinon c'est
accessible à tout le monde sans problème
ici c'est pour le départ on est sur une
sculpture de mondineu rue le nôtre et
puis ensuite on va se diriger vers la
perspective de marta pan suivez-moi
alors on est si donc face à la
perspective de marta pan qui est composé
de trois éléments fondamentaux donc les
engouffrons mans juste derrière nous et
puis la perspective les anneaux et le
pied ça fait un an qu'on voit sur l'eau
alors on est ici sur les imprimés
arcades du lac construit par ricardo
bofill en 1986 et puis derrière nous le
petit versailles qui abrite aujourd'hui
plus de 200 logements sociaux
en coulisse y avait un tour au niveau du
technocentre sont retoqués juste
derrière vous ses architectes ont
travaillé à la conception du bâtiment
aux lignes futuristes
on travaille également ici au prototype
des véhicules de demain on peut dire que
c'est une vraie ville dans la ville est
d'ailleurs l'axé il est très réglementée
et ses balades d'été sont proposées par
l'office de tourisme et juste devant je
suis allé à la rencontre de valérie
ferrée pour en parler plus longuement
valérie ferrer c'est la directrice de
l'office
allez on se trouve maintenant en
compagnie de valérie ferrer la
directrice de l'office de tourisme de
saint quentin en yvelines bonjour à
l'airé libre enchères on se trouve à
l'entrée du parc des sources de la
bièvre avec vous on va parler des
ballades que propose l'office de
tourisme noyer volontiers qu'elles sont
là quelle est la philosophie de ces
balades et combien vous en proposer pour
cet été alors les balades la philosophie
c'est juste prendre l'air prendre du bon
temps découvrir la nature découvrir
l'art et se mettre un petit peu au sport
cet été on en propose cinq nouvelles
mais on a déjà une collection qui est
bien complète à l'office de tourisme
déjà depuis trois quatre ans donc on
peut venir l'office de tourisme on
trouve des fiches ultra détaillé voilà
savoir comment ils concernés y compris
des balades spécifique pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite ou qui ont
des poussettes etc donc il ya déjà
beaucoup de ballades de proposer sur le
territoire cette année on en propose 5
supplémentaires avec un un côté un peu
ludique dans le graphisme tout
simplement dans la présentation donc
c'est une nouvelle collection donc on
espère qu'elle aura du succès aussi fait
des balades qui font à peu près combien
de kilos mais qui sont adaptables même
si on n'est pas sportif parce que
jean-pierre sont pas forcément des ultra
sportif non on a essayé de s'adapter
effectivement à tous les publics on va
de la balade très familial avec les
poussettes pour aller de deux sites de
jardins d'éveil de jeu sur elle en cours
notamment parce qu'ils ont un patrimoine
assez intéressant et puis on peut aller
jusqu'à des balades sur manille à vélo
qui sont beaucoup plus costaud et qui
demande même de la tension mais s'est
signalé s'est précisée sur les fiches on
les met en garde parce qu'il ya des
descentes un peu un peu verte impérieuse
voilà c'est à peu près de combien de
kilomètres par exemple sur manille
surman il y en a une alors c'est plus en
temps je renvoie
tout le monde la bonne n'a pas la même
capacité donc on était alors en temps si
on les fait à pied ça peut aller jusqu'à
3 heures si on les fait à vélo et qu'on
roule bien ça peut faire une heure mais
après il faut on compte pas de dans les
temps de pause puisque on propose aussi
de s'arrêter dans des restaurants des
cafés faire un plongeon dans la piscine
pourquoi pas donc on peut vraiment
adapté la balade à nos envies au temps
qu'il fait est que ces temps il ya
vraiment un côté du lycée voilà c'est ça
s'est construit autour effectivement
pouvoir s'arrêter pour voir prendre un
peu de bon temps il ya aussi une balade
qui est uniquement réservé aux relais
n'est pas uniquement réservé aux rollers
mais en tout cas qu est accessible aux
rollers oui tout à fait on a voulu aussi
promouvoir leurs lampes qui on a de plus
en plus de personnes qui souhaitent se
soumettre à ce sport donc du coup voilà
on a trouvé un circuit qui part de saint
quentin et puis qui va jusqu au
technocentre nos qui fait une boucle et
qui revient jusqu'à 50 ans donc
l'appareil on peut foncer où elle est
plus plus tranquillement on peut emmener
les enfants où il ya les entre adultes
au choix vous avez vis et ludique est à
la fois on parle aussi du patrimoine
parce qu'on apprend des choses à
l'occasion de ces de ses balades des
points de repère comme ça où on apprend
des choses oui mais bien sûr saint
quentin en yvelines et en accueillant un
riche patrimoine
évidemment on a souhaité le mettre en
valeur donc à l'occasion de ces balades
il y a des points d'intérêt qui sont
mentionnés qui explique un peu
l'histoire de l'architecturé ou bien du
site d'un point de vue environnemental
historique voilà on a essayé de faire un
petit résumé aussi de ce qu'on pouvait
voir lors de ses balades est-ce qu'on
peut rappeler où est-ce qu'on peut les
trouver ces balades à l'ordre à l'office
de tourisme il ya peut-être d'autres
sites d'autres moyens pour se le
procurer alors en premier lieu on va se
les procurer dans petit quentin de
juillet août
là il ya un supplément qui est insérée
dans le petit quentin de juillet août et
puis après à disposition effectivement à
l'office de tourisme
et puis téléchargeable sur le site
et puis aussi au travers d'un ebook que
voilà qu'on va pouvoir mettre en ligne
dès le début du mois de juillet donc on
non on saura tout voilà hockey autre
chose à ajouter sur ces balades on
espère qu on espère qu'il fera beau
c'est surtout ça parce que c'est vrai
que avec un temps un peu maussade c'est
un peu plus compliqué mais de toute
façon elles sont une fois qu'elles sont
là elles pourront être faites à
l'automne elles pourront être faites
l'année prochaine pour une dernière
saison oui excusez moi et puisqu'on
voulait dire aussi c'est que ces balades
c'est le début d'une collection puisque
je vous ai dit ça on a changé
complètement de graphisme etc donc on
incite tous les toutes les personnes qui
aiment se balader à saint quentin à
venir nous voir à construire d'autres
balades ensemble pour qu'on puisse
étoffer cette nouvelle collection et
qu'on s'enrichit des expériences des uns
et des autres donc ça peut être
participative tout à fait donc ses
locaux à l'arrêt 14 sportifs si vous
aimez des baladins n'hésitez pas à venir
l'office de tourisme venir proposer de
les promener d'un peu original en tout
cas sur le territoire de 50 en ligne et
puis une dernière chose c'est gratuit
ces fiches sont gratuits l'on peut venir
proposer gratuitement à l'office de
tourisme veut aussi c'est une notion
importante merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup